[Music]
this morning on the dish a return visit
from missy robbins she runs two of the
best italian restaurants in the world
and has put together a beautiful new
book pasta based on her travels and
recipes for robins the past few years in
particular have been a roller coaster
professionally and personally we talked
about all of it and sampled more than
you can count
during our visit with her
we really set out to to make something
that would feel timeless missy robbins
grew up an ocean away from the focus of
her new book
pasta the spirit and craft of italy's
greatest food a jewish girl raised in a
kosher household in connecticut
she took a transformational trip to
italy in her twenties after serving as
an executive chef in chicago and new
york she opened her first restaurant
lilia in brooklyn in 2016.
that was followed two years later by
missy
at both spots
dough
turns into art you list
45
different pasta shapes in the book
and that if i'm understanding this
correctly is just scratching the surface
totally i mean i i there are thousands
of pasta shapes and also they get
intertwined with different names i mean
there are 400 things that are called
ravioli alone there's 400 things you
know my tortelli looks totally different
than my neighbor's tortelli one of the
big things you talk about in the book
everybody i think knows that making
fresh pasta can be challenging yes and
laborious
cooking pasta is challenging as well oh
yeah the right way yes you know there's
not just like boiling the pasta it's
like how is your water salted is it
salted enough never ever put oil in your
water please don't ever put oil on your
water because you'll never be able to
get to the next point which is marriage
and the marriage ceremony which is
really kind of it so you always want to
finish your pasta in the sauce
and don't drain the water never drain
the water why so when you cook pasta in
water some of that starch comes out
and that becomes part of the sauce pasta
water is key it's an ingredient
just one of the many lessons robin
shares from a career and life that in
the past several years has seen both her
greatest triumphs and her biggest
challenges
she was diagnosed with breast cancer in
2017.
now recovered she also totally changed
her lifestyle in her 40s
you've talked openly you've written
about this you've talked about it about
your struggles with weights yeah i was
40 plus pounds more than i am today
and i was unhealthy like i wasn't
breathing correctly
i i just didn't feel good um and it's
not healthy and i it's really like no
other kind of addictive behavior my vice
has always been food ironically
i had really
bad sort of tasting habits in the
kitchen her new diet does include yes
less pasta
which doesn't mean dish segments can't
be occasional splurge opportunities
okay so we have i'm going to start with
veg
grilled broccoli sharp provolone
garlic bread crumbs that was followed by
beans and grilled escarole
leeks with anchovy vinaigrette parsley
and pistachio
and artichokes braised and grilled
topped with mint salsa verde i used to
love artichokes when i was a kid
so these are first cooked in
olive oil and
wine and a lot of aromatics and then
they're grilled when you order them
the sauce is amazing
the mint's so fresh
you're going to eat every single thing
why not that's amazing do you want a
little plate no i want you to which was
good because we were just getting
started
next was whipped ricotta on grilled
sourdough
served with roasted mushrooms preserved
in olive oil this looks like it could
change your life it doesn't matter what
i put with it people are not ordering it
because of the vegetable they're
ordering it because of that 100 and it's
like the most instagram dish i've ever
seen
wow
moving on to pasta we have tortelli
this is a spinach and mascarpone filled
pasta finished with brown butter there
was also meze rigatoni with her
signature 30 clove sauce
chickpea pepper deli with rosemary
parmesan and lemon
bucatini with enduja
and gnocchi sardi or malariatis with a
fennel saffron and pork sausage sauce
and this is another pasta shape though
that we talked about we're like yeah
similar to other ones yeah each one of
those is done by hand on a little board
every single one each one of these each
that is not done by a machine that is
done by a human
their work is worth wow wow that smile i
think you just found your favorite
i think that is my favorite my favorite
too while you won't find it listed on
the menu the only entree available at
missy is bisteca fiorentina
it's marinated in garlic and rosemary
and finished with olive oil lemon and
fennel pollen all that was followed by a
presentation of seven different kinds of
gelato
one featuring olive oil olive oil ice
cream yes
we also had chocolate chocolate chip
pistachio espresso fiordi latte and
hazelnuts though for me
it was all about the mint chocolate chip
oh wow
yeah fresh mint
oh my gosh
this is novel and really cool but that's
my favorite all right well keep going we
did
our feast was accompanied by a cocktail
that's become one of robin's specialties
what is this this is the missy spritz
this is the missy spritz yes
thank you so much for having me
are you going to try the steak
oh yeah
i mean i did thank you jeff thank you i
did try it i'm going to brooklyn today i
didn't check
seven gelatos seven gelato and the steak
and all the pasta or veggies or her
veggies are great what was bleeped out
what did you say yeah yeah well we'd
have to keep it now
i'd let the crew know that i was
interested in eating some of the food
how dare you forget it that was in a
direct way we have um we have some of
the whipped ricotta here here we go nice
one to sample yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then i'll go get the gelato
whoa um
once again getting it
mm-hmm and then you can
then you can
yeah
and some pasta but some good tips right
you learn your tips
without a doubt well listen handmade
this is delicious